7 Movie Plots That Make Absolutely No Sense
Intro
Plot Holes or unexplained questions are nothing
new to Hollywood blockbuster, but sometimes,
a movie's logic problems go a lot deeper than
dangling plot threads.
Sometimes, the movie itself doesn't make sense,
since it's plot holes are so obvious, audiences
are guaranteed to wonder if the filmmakers
are trying to trick them.
Here are Screen Rant's 7 Movie Plots That
Make Absolutely No Sense.
Frozen
As Disney movies go, the twist of Frozen was
actually surprising, when the gentlemanly
Prince Hans is revealed as the villain in
disguise, only wanting to marry Princess Anna
so he could take out the Queen, and rule the
country of Arendelle himself.
There's one problem, though - actually, TWO.
For starters, he decides to charge Queen Elsa
with treason - a challenge, since she can't
really commit a crime against the state, since
she's the Queen - she is the state.
But his plan to become king makes zero sense:
if Elsa and Anna both died, he wouldn't become
king, the throne would go to the next living
blood relative.
Furious Seven
The plot of the seventh Furious adventure
is far-fetched to begin with, but it follows
one simple idea: after the villain, Deckard
Shaw, kills one of Dom's crew and puts his
sister's family in danger, his team sets out
to track him down, and stop him for good.
But to find him, they need a sophisticated
program called God's Eye to search for his
face on every camera in the world.
The team heads off on a dangerous mission
to get the program - but is interrupted by
Shaw, attacking the team that's trying to
attack him.
You would think the crew would slam on the
brakes having found their man, but they don't.
He stays hot on their heels for the rest of
the movie, with the stars never realizing
they should just stop moving.
Armageddon
When an asteroid the size of Texas is found
flying towards Earth, NASA gets creative,
hiring a deep sea drilling crew to fly up
to the space rock, and drill an explosive
into its core.
It's a nightmare for NASA, having to turn
a group of roughnecks into astronauts in a
matter of days.
But star Ben Affleck asked director Michael
Bay the same question we keep wondering: Why
wouldn't NASA just get the crew to teach their
astronauts to drill, safely, one an everyday
rig?
Bay just told him to shut up, since he'd also
realized the movie doesn't make a lick of
sense.
The Matrix
Morpheus makes it clear that in the world
of The Matrix, the agents are the greatest
threat, since every person in the system can
be taken over by them in a second.
It begs the question: when the agents realized
Morpheus was trying to contact Neo, they planted
a tracker into his stomach.
A tracker they never follow, before or after
it's removed.
They probably should have, since it would've
led them to their enemies' secret hideout.
Why didn't they?
It's not like they have other hobbies or a
need to sleep, so the fact that they just
let Neo be recruited - then spend the rest
of the movie trying to kill him and his friends
- is downright cheating on the Wachowskis'
part.
And even with two sequels, there's no explanation
other than it being an old fashioned gaping
plot hole.
Star Wars
This space Saga all started when a boy named
Luke Skywalker's learned that he was actually
the son of a great hero, who had fallen to
become one of the galaxy's greatest villains.
Things get worse when his identity is revealed,
but think for a second: Obi-Wan went to the
trouble of hiding Luke.
But apparently, made sure that his aunt and
uncle, who Vader had met, would still call
him by his father's last name.
Oh, and be sure to tell him that his father
was Anakin, the former pilot and adventurer
he should idolize and escape to become.
If Luke's aunt and uncle just claim Luke as
their son, he lives his life quietly.
The even dumber fact is that Darth Vader never
even investigates whether someone was claiming
to be Anakin's son - or sensed his own child
when he was just a few feet away.
Looper
We won't even point out the problems or time
travel contradictions in the one, since it's
all in the name of telling a cool story.
It works, but if you take even a tiny look
at the actual looper system, it makes zero
sense.
A future crime boss sends his targets into
the past, since they can't be disposed of
in his own time.
But instead of hiring, then eventually killing
a horde of hitmen, why wouldn't he just send
his enemies a few decades into the past - or
send their bodies?
If they need to be alive to time travel, poison
them!
There are hundreds of ways of getting what
he's after, but the movie claims he picked
the absolute worst one imaginable.
The Terminator
When the robot armies of Skynet realize they've
lost the war, they send a Terminator back
in time to kill Sarah Connor, the mother of
mankind's greatest hero, John Connor.
Even though plenty of women by that time are
killed, John's mother lives to train her son
to become the leader she knows he will be.
But why wouldn't she also tell him to change
his name?
Skynet wouldn't have been able to even try
to kill him or his mother if he used a false
name.
Erasing the threat before it ever began.
Those are the plot holes so big, they turn
some of our favorite movies into nonsensical
stories.
But which ones have we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and be sure to
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this.